this is the a100 chip from the US giant
Nvidia it's one of the world's most
advanced Computing processors which
helps develop artificial intelligence
that's used in everything from
self-driving cars to making drugs and
even building weapons
and this is one of its newest
competitors made by a Chinese startup
industry analysts who track the speed of
Chip say this model is even faster than
the a100 based on initial tests It
produced performances that were
significantly more competitive than
previous AI chips coming from China
here's how the design and capabilities
of these two chips compare as the race
for dominance in Tech is ramping up
the U.S has been a Pioneer in the
semiconductor industry for over 70 years
the U.S essentially gave birth to the
semiconductor industry and the
semiconductor economy Wayne lamb is the
director of research with tech
consulting firm CCS insight for over a
decade he has been researching American
chip technology the U.S was an ideal
place because it started much of the
research and core Sciences in the late
1940s American scientists invented the
first transistor the fundamental
technology behind all chips early
versions of chips fit inside computers
that helped calculate projectiles and
get NASA space programs off the ground
but the industry really took off in the
1960s with the rising demand for
consumer goods like televisions and
corporate computers
that boom also drove chip companies to
spring up across Asia with Taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company now
leading the industry making more than 90
percent of the world's most advanced
chips still today the US is home to some
of the world's leading chip designers
and they help power everything from our
smartphones to laptops and data centers
China on the other hand has long been
trailing the U.S and for several decades
it is actually relied on American
companies as well as chip makers in
Taiwan and Japan
in 2021 China imported more than 430
billion dollars worth of chips exceeding
that of oil so Chinese president Xi
Jinping has made it a top priority to
change that it's absolutely important on
a strategic basis Gregory Allen is a
senior fellow at the center for
strategic and International Studies a
think tank based in Washington DC he's
been following beijing's Ai and
semiconductor policies for about seven
years
what they essentially wanted in the
semiconductor industry was for more of
the chips that were used in China to be
made in China so to become more
self-reliant Beijing promised to provide
about 180 billion dollars in state
funding to support its domestic chip
industry
the goal is to design chips that can be
as fast as the American ones like this
AI chip from Nvidia and this model
released in August by b-ren is the
latest demonstration of China's progress
like its American rival the b-ren chip
is also a graphics Processing Unit or
GPU and both are designed to help
computers perform complex tasks faster
so what makes a chip powerful
to improve their performance both
companies are using the same type of
transistor
fundamental unit that basically controls
the flow of electronic signals and that
allows the chips to store data or run
calculations
but unlike the first transistor invented
in the 1940s the ones today are so small
that they are measured in nanometers
which is a fraction of the width of a
human hair seven nanometer transistors
are now the base for both Nvidia and
b-ren's high-end chips so smaller to the
transistor the more transistors you can
pack into the same surface area of a
silicon the American ship is designed
with more than 54 billion transistors
over a plate of about 800 millimeter
square whereas the br100 is slightly
bigger with about 77 billion transistors
packed into about 1 000 Square
millimeters
while there are many factors that
determine a Chip's performance industry
experts say having a higher number of
transistors can help increase the
Chinese processor's speed brn says its
chip can perform more than one thousand
trillion operations per second at its
peak write it out that's 15 zeros that's
about three times the stated speed of
nvidia's a100
but whether biren will be able to
dominate the market will require more
than designing chips reducing them is
also a huge challenge because it
requires precise manufacturing to
squeeze these billions of transistors
onto a tiny surface semiconductor
manufacturing is perhaps the most
technologically complicated thing that
the human species does one of the most
complex processes is called lithography
which blasts UV light through photo
masks and prints patterns on Silicon
Wafers adding layers to form the
transistors you need to be precise some
of the layers in the semiconductor
transistors are only one atom thick so
Nvidia and biren both look to another
company for manufacturing you may have
guessed that's the Taiwan semiconductor
Manufacturing Company the world's
largest contract chip producer
but Buren's Reliance on tsmc is becoming
a hurdle on its way to rivaling Nvidia
it has been sort of a cautionary tale
for the Chinese semiconduct in history
a couple of months after the Chinese
startup released its chip the Biden
Administration imposed new export
restrictions the rules barred
cutting-edge semiconductors made with
American Technologies from being sold to
China and because tsmc uses equipment
from U.S companies mirin is at risk of
losing the Taiwanese chipmaker as a
supplier this dramatically reduces
b-ren's prospects for its future as a
leading chip designer biren didn't
respond to a request for comment
tsmc says it complies with all laws and
regulations but declined to comment on
specific customers
China also depends on a handful of
American companies that dominate the
industry for advanced manufacturing
equipment with the American government
blocking China from buying these
machines it becomes even harder for
Beijing to build its own high-end chip
making factories
that development is perfectly an effort
to say the least so it would require
considerable investment in capital and
time to make that happen
China isn't alone in facing challenges
and trying to become more
self-sufficient while the U.S leads in
design and research it is also long
relied on outside manufacturers like
tsmc and Samsung and South Korea
and the vulnerability of that dependence
became an issue during the pandemic when
a chip shortage hit companies large and
small prompting President Biden to
promise that more semiconductors would
be produced in the U.S this is
infrastructure
so look we need to build infrastructure
of today not repair the one of yesterday
so in August he signed the chips act
allocating more than 52 billion dollars
in federal aid for Semiconductor
research and Manufacturing tsmc later
announced that it would invest 40
billion dollars to build two factories
in Arizona these Investments are helping
us build and strengthen the supply chain
here in America
and only months after the release of
China's br100 Nvidia announced that it
will release a super fast new chip which
would in turn beat b-runs the long and
expensive race to develop chips that'll
drive the future of AI is entering a new
phase